and after one week I say you know let's
let's be frontal let's be honest with
the kids let's let's say that
angel which is the name they go to the
to the heaven
it's better to say in that way Cristiano
Ronaldo opening up about the loss of his
infant son for sure his ashes is with me
it's something that it's I want to hold
for the rest of my life in April the
Soccer Star and girlfriend Georgina
Rodriguez shared tragic news their
newborn daughter's twin brother died
during childbirth and seven months later
Cristiano sitting down with Piers Morgan
and Pastor in that moment was probably
the most difficult moment that I had in
my life me and my my family especially
and revealing how they brought the
devastating news to their children and
after one week I say you know let's
let's be frontal let's be honest with
the kids let's let's say that angel
which is the name they go to the to the
heaven
it's better to say in that way the
couple were already parents to Alana Eva
and Mateo and Cristiano his dad the 12
year old Cristiano Jr in the beginning
do you arrive in home and that the kids
start to say where's another baby
where's another baby of course Cristiano
had conversation with him
in the in the day
and because he's 12 years old he knows
he understand everything and I had a
nice conversation with him we cried
together in his bedroom Cristiano
remembers their conflicting emotions was
difficult to be honest as the couple
grieved for their son their family also
welcomed a daughter Esmerelda I tried to
explain sometimes to my family and even
my close friends they say I never felt
to be happy and sad in the same moment
yes I never felt it is hard to explain
um so difficult so difficult it's you
don't know if you cry you don't know if
you smile yes because it's something
that
you don't know how to react you don't
know what to do to be honest Cristiano
and Georgina have been together since
2017 and last year they announced on
Instagram she was expecting twins
writing alongside sonogram photos quote
our hearts are full of love we can't
wait to meet you
is
Georgina documented her pregnancy
Journey on social media
following Angel's death the couple said
quote it is the greatest pain that any
parents can feel it is probably the
worst moment that I passed through my
life since my
my father died you know when you have a
kid that you expect that everything will
be normal and you have that uh problem
it's it's hard you know as human being
that I am in Georgina why we had quite
difficult moments because
we don't understand why
happened to us
[Music]